oh god just kind of winging it oops ah
it burst
oh oh oh no
abort abort i'm a mess there's like a
salt
bomb it's beautiful shut up they're done
hi i'm alexis and i'm a chef who's
always up for a challenge
today i've asked the internet what
appliance i should make a three-course
meal out of
i'm gonna taste everything myself and i
have no idea what's in this box
so let's get started
[Music]
oh oh i think this is an egg cooker
oh no i've never used net cooker
i imagine this gets pretty hot but i
wonder if you need to have this on it is
everything gonna be steamed that's so
boring
i don't feel good about this confidence
level is
like a two oh god
this is going to be really hard egg
cookers are used for
making eggs i'm not going to make eggs
in this that feels like the easy way out
and
i don't like to make things easy on
myself and it looks like we've got a few
options there's a rapid one there's
double decker one
so i think if i remove all these like
handy things i don't know maybe i'll end
up using them
stay tuned this is just like gonna be
one big steam basket so i think there's
a lot to do
the one thing i'm a little wary of is i
don't know how hot these actually get
i think my confidence level at this
point is five
we'll see when i actually start cooking
how that changes so i'm gonna work
backwards and start with dessert
so i'm making crepes my mom's dutch and
i grew up with
crepes or we called them dutch pancakes
you know i don't think i had an american
pancake until i was like
seven eight so when i think of pancakes
this is what i think of
and i'm just gonna kind of wing it with
alternating flour
and milk so maybe i'll add like a pinch
of
sugar so when i made the crepes with the
clothing irons there was a lot of
surface area i also needed to put a mold
on it it just felt like it was spongy
but i think this
could work a little better i feel like
this is my crepe redemption
[Music]
gonna add some vanilla extract okay egg
cooker on
that's easy at least so butter needs to
go in here
and then i think water has to go in here
it's warming up but will it get hot okay
so the water's actually boiling
like really aggressively and the butter
is melting i wonder if i put
too much water in because it looks like
it's like kind of trying to spurt out
oh god i just need the butter to turn
i would say don't try this at home this
is definitely a no don't try at home
situation
okay so twist that doesn't look totally
great but let's just you know
first pancake let's try a test okay and
then i guess i'll put the little hat on
and wait this feels aggressive this
feels like i've done
something wrong i guess i could just
lift it and see what's happening
okay there's there's we're learning
we're learning some lessons
i think i put way too much water in
feels like it shouldn't be so
aggressively like
rocking or like a gentle steam
it also feels like it's getting wet like
the water is like
leaping up and wetting the crepe which
sounds
disgusting you remember how a few
minutes ago i was like this is my crepe
redemption
i don't know if that's true my
confidence is
wavering we're like still at a five oh
oh
abort abort oh no it's so
floppy look you can see it bouncing it
is literally like a wet floppy pancake
it looks like a fungus
i need to reframe i need to take a
minute maybe i should
test it
[Music]
no oh wow so bad this is certainly not
great redemption this is disgusting
this is so gross but you know i think i
can fix it
i'm gonna doctor up the batter i'm gonna
get this water out we're gonna
reframe so i know i was like
shaming these little funny
things before i don't know what they're
called little egg holders but
i think this is actually gonna help hold
this up so it's stabilized and not like
rocking on the water
also i don't need to pour all of the
water in so i'm going to do a really
thin layer
butter okay this is looking so much
better
now the hat perfect
you can kind of look it slide in like
that look it doesn't look great i know
this you know this but
okay but look how thin that is look at
that i know this sounds weird but i just
wanna like i just the wet pancake thing
is like
really gross this looks good this looks
really pretty good but if you roll it up
that is so pretty
oh my god thank god this works
it's not the best script i've ever had
but it's totally passable and with sugar
on top
it's gonna be great this is for sure now
a great redemption
this is like significantly better i
think i'm actually gonna make three of
these
because it's just gonna look prettier
what if i should put the berries around
first and then some powdered sugar
i don't know this is kind of like as
good as it's gonna get i feel i feel
good about it moving on
before i move on to the appetizer i'm
gonna marinate my salmon it's gonna be
like a really
simple miso ginger
soy situation i i love miso so much
there's like a salt bomb i'm going to
use like a tiny little bit of brown
sugar a bit of soy sauce and some
vinegar
this is like really all about balancing
the flavors a little bit of
sesame oil sesame oil goes a really long
way
so you'll need to use a little bit gonna
add a little ginger
oh it smells so good let's just pour it
over
yum looks great okay
beautiful i'm gonna wash my hands pop
this in the fridge
and move on to the dumplings vegetable
dumplings i've made dumplings in a few
months but
it's pretty easy to do so i'm going to
use some shredded carrots i've got some
really beautiful shiitake mushrooms
some napa cabbage it's like as big as my
head trying to keep everything
about the same size so pretty some
scallions
i'm gonna do tofu and you can just kind
of like crumble it i'm gonna add a
little cilantro too
it smells amazing sesame oil yum that
looks so
good i'm just rinse my hands off and
then it's dumpling making time
so i've got these like really cute
little wrappers
first step
is to get a spoon you know obviously if
this is like
tight together you can only add like a
little bit so you can add like a
teaspoon of filling
wow even that maybe i should have
chopped it smaller
and then take your finger and some water
and just go all the way around that i
like to do like a little pleat
there are people that are so much better
than me at this
so you can check out this amazing video
inga did making dumplings
from scratch much cooler than this you
know since i have two
of these little i was gonna call them
steamers little egg cookers
i think i'm gonna do like three at a
time also i feel certain this is gonna
work
you know if the crepes worked there's no
reason why they shouldn't
it's so cute i think for this purpose
six is enough
a little layer of water look how cute
that is wow
i imagine this is going to take a few
minutes i'm going to make a little
dipping sauce
in the meantime a little soy sauce
some rice vinegar smidge of sesame oil
and i'm going to add some like thinly
sliced ginger and i'm gonna just see
what they're like
oh this is so cool they're like done i
think they're done
shut up they're done oh
my god they're so perfect they're so
perfect oh
wow wow is it weird i feel like you
never have cilantro over but some green
feels pretty
okay dumplings done confidence is a 10.
i've already got my fish marinated just
gonna blot
the marinade off should have taken this
off
and i think this guy's going to fit in
same method as before
i feel like i was pretty negative about
the egg cooker
and i just want to apologize to everyone
who loves them because i think
they're very cool okay so for my bok
choy hmm
this is quite small so maybe i'll start
with this
little one just like nestle it all
together
and i imagine the bok choy is going to
cook pretty
fast going to slice some scallions to go
on top
so i just wait this seems very chill
okay it's already it's
it's already cooking it's already
cooking bok choy has
no ways to go that's okay oh maybe it's
done
oh it might be overcooked
it feels quite firm i don't know why i
grabbed a spatula it was a panic
it was a panic move i would say that's
the downside of this whole thing but
things keep getting really wet perfect
bok choy beautiful whoops this is like a
very healthy meal salmon and bok choy
he's gonna put a little soy
over the bok choy and some sesame seeds
and some scallions can go over you know
my plating is not my strong point today
but i think this is great
i think this is great i think this is
gonna be really good and
the fact that it was cooked in an egg
cooker is like crazy
i'm not as impressed with myself as it
was with the dumplings but i'm gonna
give this a solid 8.5
we'll see how it tastes you guys it
looks amazing it's beautiful
i'm honestly like so proud of myself so
first up the dumplings
they're just the cutest they're so cute
[Music]
i mean it's crazy that that was done at
cougar they're delicious
they're lovely i'm gonna give these a
time moment of truth with the salmon
oh shut up look at that
who can see this who can see this this
might be pink for some people this is
perfect for me
[Music]
hmm it's fresh it feels really clean
i guess that's why people steam salmon
okay bok choy
i mean steamboat delicious another 10.
that's great it's really great okay this
i've gotta be honest it's not gonna be a
dead
they're fine they're like a little weird
if someone else made these for me i'd be
like
you know oh yikes but i think for an egg
cooker
they're like a solid six overall
i feel like this is like a really good
meal and i feel really proud of myself
let me know in the comments what you
would make in an egg cooker
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you